die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin schönen guten Abend wir
haben alles Wichtige vom Tage und dazu
gehört auch sportliches mit Katja streso
ja Fußball und Winter Wintersport heute
bei uns schön guten Abend wir blicken
auf unsere
Themen geiselgruppe freigelassen die
Hamas übergibt 13 Israelis an das Rote
Kreuz weitere sollen in den nächsten
Tagen
folgen früher Schluss als geplant wegen
der Haushaltskrise will Finanzminister
Lindner die Strom und gaspreisbremse zum
Jahreswechsel
beenden weitere Warnstreiks
wahrscheinlich die
lockführergewerkschaft GDL erklärt die
Tarifverhandlungen mit der Bahn für
gescheitert nach Wochen des Bangens und
Hoffens heute ein Zeichen der Zuversicht
für betroffene Angehörige eine im
Gazastreifen festgehaltene Gruppe von
Geiseln ist seit dem Nachmittag frei
unter ihnen sollen auch mindestens drei
deutschisraelis sein die 13 Frauen und
Kinder wurden am Nachmittag übergeben
außerdem 11 asiatische Staatsbürger in
den nächsten Tagen sind weitere
Freilassungen geplant für jede
israelische Geisel sollen im Gegenzug
drei palästinensische Häftlinge aus
Gefängnissen freikommen die ersten heute
Abend auch hier geht's zunächst um
Frauen und Minderjährige l
walpott es sind die Bilder auf die die
Menschen in Israel seit Wochen gewartet
haben in rafabringen Mitarbeit des Roten
Kreuzes eine erste Gruppe von Geiseln
die die Hamas freigelassen hat über die
Grenze nach Ägypten vier Kinder neun
Frauen unter ihnen auch eine Mutter und
ihre zwei Töchter mit deutschenem Pass
außerdem weitere elf Geiseln aus
Thailand und den
Philippinen Freude bei den Familien der
entführten in Tel Aviv heute Abend aber
auch weiter quälende
Ungewissheit es ist traurig dass immer
noch welche dort sind es tut ein
bisschen weh für diese Menschen aber wir
hoffen
weiter als Gegenleistung wurden in
Israel 39 palästinensische Häftlinge
Jugendliche und Frauen in einer
Haftanstalt zusammengelegt sie sollen am
Abend freigelassen werden für tausende
Flüchtlinge im Gazastreifen war die
vereinbarte Feuerpause heute die erste
Gelegenheit seit Kriegsbeginn um
ungefährdet nach Freunden und Verwandten
zu suchen sich zu vergewissern was aus
ihrer Wohnung und ihrem Hab und Gut
geworden
ist
ich muss zu unserem Haus das liegt
östlich von chunis so etwas wie diesen
Krieg hatten wir noch nie in unserer
Geschichte das Haus von Familie alnad
für das sie sich hoch verschuldet hatten
liegt in
Trümmern schauen Sie sich diese ganze
Verwüstung hier an die Bilder sind
stärker als alle Worte was soll ich noch
sagen wer wird uns
helfen den Zugang zum nördlichen
Gazastreifen hat die israelische Armee
als Kampfgebiet
gesperrt Teil der Vereinbarung wurden
heute auch verstärkt Hilfslieferungen in
den Gasastreifen gebracht in den
kommenden vier Tagen sollen 200
Lastwagen täglich Lebensmittel und
Treibstoff
liefern in Tel Aviv dort wo sich die
geiselangehörigen jeden Tag versammeln
ist Michael beverunge für uns Michael
konnten die freigelassenen ihre liebsten
schon in die Arme
schließen das noch nicht aus deutscher
Sicht ist natürlich eine besonders große
Freude dass unter den drei
freigelassenen Geiseln auch drei mit
deutscher Staatsbürgerschaft sind eine
Mutter mit ihren zwei kleinen Kindern
hier auf dem Platz hat das gerade keine
große Rolle gespielt als die ersten
Bilder kamen wie die Busse zum ersten
Mal über die israelische Grenze fuhren
und klar war jetzt sind die geisens
Sicherheit da brandete hier Beifall aus
und der gilt allen Geiseln das wird ja
auch immer klar gemacht alle freuen sich
hier für jeden Angehörigen dessen
Familienmitglieder freigelassen werden
für die für die Geiseln ist es so dass
sie jetzt erstmal sich noch auf einer
Militärbasis im Süden befinden danach da
werden sie untersucht können auch erste
Telefonate mit ihren Familienangehörigen
machen und dann geht es weiter in
weitere Hospitäler oder Hotels wo sie
dann auch persönlich ihre Angehörigen
treffen und dann gibt es noch mal einen
ganz ganz schwierigen Moment weil im
Lauf der nächsten Stunden muss dann
Ihnen
möglichst möglichenfalls noch mal schon
beigebracht werden dass in der Zeit wo
sie ja von allen informtion weitgehend
abgeschnitten waren dass sie eben nicht
mitbekommen haben dass auch Freunde
Verwandte nächste Eheleute Kinder
gestorben sind oder schwer verletzt sind
das wird noch mal eine ganz schwierige
Aufgabe und so geht es dann
wahrscheinlich auch den nächsten Tage
weiter jeden Tag in den nächsten vier
Tagen Z bis mehr israelische Geiseln
gegen die dreifache Anzahl an
palästinensischen Häftlingen danke schön
nach telaviv zu Michael bberunge ja zum
Krieg in n Ost und den freigekommenen
Geiseln gibt's direkt im Anschluss an
uns auch ein ZDF
Spezial jetzt zur Haushaltskrise und
ihren Folgen die energiepreisbremse die
werden oder bremsen muss man ja sagen
werden schon zum Jahresende auslaufen so
Finanzminister Lindner heute im
Deutschlandfunk schon gestern kündigte
er einen Nachtragshaushalt für 2023 an
und der Kanzler eine entsprechende
Erklärung insgesamt allgemeine verun
Sicherung in Teilen auch bei der
heutigen Bundesratssitzung aus Berlin
Daniel
ponzen nachdem er gestern das erklären
musste was er stets abgelehnt hatte das
nochmalige Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse
zeigte sich der Finanzminister heute
morgen gut gelaunt bei der Vorstellung
einer Münze und deshalb freue ich mich
so sehr dass ich mich heute mal mit
einer Silbermünze beschäftigen muss
bevor es dann später wieder um das Geld
geht das uns
fehlt die weniger guten Nachricht
erklärte er dem Deutschlandfunk zum
31.12 dieses Jahres wird der Wirtschafts
und stabilisierungsfond geschlossen so
Lindner die Strom und gaspreisbremsen
werden ebenfalls zum Jahresende beendet
zuvor hatte der Kanzler noch betont dass
Hilfen in solchen besonderen Notlagen
weiterhin möglich sein zudem sagte er
per videostatement die Bundesregierung
halte an all ihren wesentlichen Zielen
Fest auch an der Modernisierung von
Industrie und Wirtschaft deshalb
schieben wir die nötigen Entscheidung
nicht auf die lange Bank sondern
arbeiten schon in diesem Jahr daran dass
die Bundesregierung und der Bundestag
alle Beschlüsse die für den Haushalt
2024 erforderlich sind schnell treffen
wo sonst noch gespart bzw ob Steuern
erhöht werden sollen dazu vorest nichts
Kritik aus der Union die erste Frage
muss sein Was gibt es eigentlich aktuell
an Zusagen fürs nächste Jahr was davon
ist zwingend ist die Bundesregierung in
der Lage zu priorisieren jeder Mensch
der der Pleite ist muss ich erstmal
ehrlich machen und das gilt auch für die
Bundesregierung bald nicht mehr
zuständig dafür ist der Mann der seit
vielen Jahren als Architekt des
Bundeshaushalts gilt Staatssekretär
Werner Gatzer der schon unter den
Finanzministern Steinbrück Schäuble und
Scholz diente Lindner versetzt ihn zum
Jahresende in den einstweiligen
Ruhestand dankte ihm aber ausdrücklich
für das
Geleistete zur Haushaltskrise gibt's
frische politbarometerzahlen schönen
guten Abend Matthias von hallo guten
Abend sparen Steuern hoch oder
Schuldenbremse reformieren was sagen
denn die Befragten na die Befragten
haben jedenfalls eine ziemlich klare
Meinung dazu woher das fehlende Geld
kommen soll die Ausgaben müssen gekürzt
werden das sagt eine Mehrheit von
57% höhere Steuern halten nur 11% für
richtig 23% sind dafür mehr Schulden zu
machen wo gekürzt werden könnte die
Parteien haben da ihre Vorstellungen die
FDP würde im Sozialbereich kürzen 73 70%
bezweifeln dass ihr das gelingt die
Grünen wollen Kürzungen beim Klimaschutz
verhindern 68% sagen das lässt sich
nicht verhindern es gab ja schon vor dem
Karlsruher Urteil zof in der Regierung
Matthias wie wird die Stimmung denn in
Ampel jetzt eingeschätzt na ja das
Verhältnis zwischen SPD Grünen und FDP
wird sehr negativ gesehen gerade mal 11%
glauben das Verhältnis ist gut satte
82% halten das Verhältnis der Parteien
untereinander für schlecht eine klare
Mehrheit findet dass die Regierung ihre
Arbeit eher schlecht macht trotzdem
glauben die meisten dass sie bis zur
Wahl 2025 halten wird wenn am nächsten
Sonntag schon Bundestagswahl wäre kenme
die SPD auf 15% -1 die Union 31 + 1
grüne 15 FDP 5 beide unverändert AFD 22
+ 1 ihr bisher Höch Wert linke
4% die Ampel wäre damit deutlich ohne
Mehrheit Matthias hab vielen Dank für
diese sehr interessanten zahlen und das
ausführliche ZDF Politbarometer gibt's
dann heute abend ab 22:10 Uhr im heute
journal oder jederzeit online auf ZDF
heute dort sehen sie dann alle Daten
auch die Top 10 der beliebtesten
Politiker der Bundesrat hat mehrere
Gesetze Vorhaben der Ampelkoalition
gestoppt beim Wachstumspaket zu
Steuererleichterung für Unternehmen
sieht eine Mehrheit der Länder die
Kosten unfair verteilt es muss jetzt in
den Vermittlungsausschuss ebenso wie das
Krankenhaus Transparenzgesetz vorerst
gescheitert ist eine Novelle des
Straßenverkehrsrechts die Kommunen mehr
Spielraum etwa für Busspuren und Tempo
30 Zonen geben
soll seitdem die Grünen als
Regierungsmitglied einige ihrer
Positionen z Migration oder Klima
aufweichen mussten dabei auch Fehler
machten bläst Ihnen viel rauer Wind
entgegen die Tatsache dass nun auch
viele Milliarden zum Umbau der
Wirtschaft fehlen macht die Sache nicht
besser auf ihrem Parteitag in karlsruhr
versuchen Sie sich frei schwimmen heute
ging es auch ums Personal Patrizia
Wiedemeier die alten sie sind auch die
neuen Ricarda lang und om mit nuripur
werden die nächsten zwei Jahre wieder
als Doppelspitze die Geschicke der
Grünen leiten Aufbruch und Zuversicht in
ihren
bewerbungsreden es ist die große
historische Aufgabe vor der wir stehen
Klimaschutz Wohlstand und Gerechtigkeit
miteinander zu verbinden und ich bin
davon überzeugt es gibt genau eine
einzige Partei die das hinbekommen kann
und sie heißt Bündnis 90 die Grünen es
braucht eine Partei die staatstragend
ist dass uns das zu weilen vorgeworfen
wird macht mich fertig weil es braucht
eine Partei die diesen Staat trägt und
wenn wir das nicht sind dann andere
nicht deswegen wollen sie auch starke
Kandidaten nach Europa schicken am
Nachmittag Aufstellung der Listen für
die Europawahl im nächsten Jahr die
Spitzenkandidatin formuliert wofür sie
kämpfen will für ein Europa dem der
Kampf gegen die Klimakrise gelingt für
ein Europa das eine Transformation
unserer Wirtschaft voranbringt die Klima
und Wohlstand schützt die Themen
Schuldenbremse Finanzen dazu das
Personal abgehakt so die Bilanz nach Z
Tagen stärker die Angriffe von außen je
schwieriger die Lage in der Ampel desto
geschlossener präsentiert sich die
Partei personell neu aufgestellt wollen
die Grünen der Stabilitätsanker in der
Ampel sein das ist das Signal das hier
von Karlsruhe ausgehen soll ob es jedoch
so harmonisch bleibt fraglich morgen
geht es um das höchst umstrittene Thema
Migration jetzt in die Ukraine wo der
Krieg unvermindert weitergeht der zweite
Winter hat begonnen besonders unter
russischenem schussgrade der Osten und
auch der Süden laut ukrainischer
Militärverwaltung gab es gestern im
Gebiet um Cherson drei Tote und
mindestens fünf verletzte dort trennt
nur der Fluss dinipro die Ukraine von
den russischen Streitkräften die
Menschen aus der Region Cherson
versuchen sich in Sicherheit zu bringen
und von dort berichtet Tim Kröger
Ludmila kostileva hat viel durchgemacht
sie hatte Cherson schon einmal verlassen
kam zurück wollte durchhalten aber die
Angst vor den Angriffen ist zu groß
geworden sie lässt sich
evakuieren es ist sehr schwer aber es
bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig ich habe
so sehr gehofft dass der Krieg früher zu
Ende
ist abschiedschmerz vor der Fahrt viele
wollen zu Verwandten oder Bekannten
weiter weg von der Front Arbeit finden
irgendwie durch den Winter kommen das
versuchen auch jene die bleiben in einem
Lager organisiert nat die Verteilung von
Hilfsgütern für den
Winter dieses Paket ist gut es gibt eine
Taschenlampe eine Akkulampe eine
Power hunderte Haushalte brauchen
außerdem solche Gasheizstrahler für den
Fall dass Russland wieder verstärkt
elektrizitäts oder Heizkraftwerke
angreift wir haben einen Winter
geschafft und schaffen auch diesen
natürlich haben wir Angst es gib keine
Menschen ohne
Angst asson hoffen derzeit vor allem auf
militärische Erfolge der ukrainischen
Armee auf dem linken dem russisch
besetzten Ufer despro sie hoffen dass es
dadurch ruhiger
wird das Ziel ist das linke Ufer zu
befreien wir wollen die Anzahl der
Angriffe
reduzieren noch aber ist das die
Realität als wir herson verlassen
schlagen Raketen in einem Vorort ein
später erfahren wir dass dabei drei
Menschen ums Leben gekommen sein sollen
im Tarifstreit bei der Deutschen Bahn da
stehen die Zeichen auf weitere Streiks
nur einen Tag nach Beginn der zweiten
Verhandlungsrunde hat die
lockführergewerkschaft GDL die Gespräche
für gescheitert erklärt für alle
Bahnkunden dürfte die Ungewissheit damit
noch Wochen vielleicht Monate andauern
mehr dazu von Stefanie Hein und Markus
gross gut möglich dass viele Züge bald
wieder stehen bleiben denn die
Tarifgespräche zwischen Bahn und
lockführergewerkschaft waren wohl heute
noch gar nicht richtig losgegangen der
erklärt gdlchef weselski sie für
gescheitert wir sehen keine
Möglichkeiten mit diesem Arbeitgeber
Kompromisse zu finden und bedauern
außerordentlich dass wir die Fahrgäste
die Kunden der Deutschen Bahn weiter
beeinträchtigen müssen im Kern geht es
der Gewerkschaft um eine
Arbeitszeitverkürzung von 38 auf 35
Stunden für Schichtarbeiter wie etwa
Lockführer die Bahn lehnt Gespräche
darüber ab zu teuer zu wenig
Fachpersonal über andere Themen hätte
man durchaus reden können erklärt
Personalvorstand Seiler der
Gesprächsabbruch Schuld der Gewerkschaft
wer nach dem zweiten Termin bereits
scheitern erklärt und vor dem zweiten
Termin bereits die Urabstimmung
einleitet das sieht man schon sehr
deutlich wie viel Raum denn verlösungen
am Ende gegeben wird eigentlich so gut
wie gar nichts reisende müssen sich
möglicherweise schon in der kommenden
Woche auf Warnstreiks einstellen die
Meinungen dazu sehr unterschiedlich die
Streiks in letzter Zeit sind schon
langsam auch ein bisschen nervig auch
wenn man jetzt Sony fahren möchte oder
so und dann plötzlich fallen die ganzen
Züge aus es ist auch ein gewisser
gewisses
Druckmittel was aktuell noch in Ordnung
ist aus meiner Sicht ich meine wir gehen
Richtung Weihnachten jetzt mal im Ernst
also ich habe absolut kein Verständnis
dafür einen Arbeitskampf über
Weihnachten hat die GDL allerdings
ausgeschlossen doch welchen Zeitraum das
genau betrifft steht noch nicht
fest für den Handel ist heute einer der
wichtigsten Tage des Jahres Black Friday
scheinbar überall werden sagenhafte
Preise und die besten Deals versprochen
Schnäppchenjäger schlagen hauptsächlich
online zu hoffen aber auch in Geschäften
auf satte Rabatte in den Kassen macht
sich das aber nur bedingt bemerkbar denn
viele kaufen heute zwar schon
Weihnachtsgeschenke ein geben dafür im
Advent aber weniger
aus jetzt zum Sport und der guten
Nachricht des Deutschland Katja
offensichtlich doch noch oder immer noch
Fußball spielen kann ja zumindest die
Spieler der U17 mit Cheftrainer
Christian Wück sie haben sich unter die
Top 4er Mannschaften bei der WM in
Indonesien gekämpft bei extremer Hitze
besiegten sie das Team aus Spanien mit
1:0 total erschöpft aber überglücklich
mit leidenschaftlichem Einsatz ziehen
Deutschland 17-Jährige ins WM Halbfinale
ein Spanien in der ersten Hälfte mit
mehr Ballbesitz und besseren Chancen
doch die deutschen werfen sich
erfolgreich in jeden Ball auf diesen
Kampfgeist setzt ihr Trainer auch in der
Pause wenn wir hinten zu Null spielen
und weiter so aufopferungsvoll kämpfen
das was die Deutschen ausmacht dann
werden wir das Spiel gewinnen und
genauso ist es gekommen seine nun besser
ins Spiel kommenden Jungs in der 62
Minute mit der vorentscheidenden Aktion
faul an Paris Brunner klarer Strafstoß
der Dortmunder verwandelt selbst zum 1:0
eine Führung die die deutschen bis zum
Abfiff
verteidigen ja und ebenfalls ein 1:0
Sieg feierten die spielerinen vom FC
Bayern München im zweiten Vorrundenspiel
der Champions League bei Paris
sa-germain den entscheidenden Treffer
erzielte Magdalena Eriksson in der
Minute in der Tabelle sind die Bayern
jetzt zweite hinter AS Rom die
viertelfinalchancen bleiben also gewaht
nach Spanien national und FC Barcelona
Keeper Mark andre Terstegen ist in der
spanischen Liga nicht nur als bester
Torhüter der vergangenen Saison geehrt
worden sondern auch als bester Spieler
ein Torhüter bester Spieler das gab's
noch nie in La Liga und noch zum Schnee
der auftagt der Nordischen Kombinierer
heute in Ruka Finnland war quasi auch
der winterliche Auftakt für Erik Frenzel
als Cheftrainer der Männer und der
Doppel Olympiasieger sah unter anderem
den vierten Platz von exteamkollege
Johannes rützeek
-1° und doch sind einige Fans vor Ort
Johannes ritzek geht nach dem Springen
als z mit 42 Sekunden Rückstand in die
auf der 7inhalb Kilom langen Strecke
kann der Oberdorfer ordentlich aufholen
im schlussspur sind die Norweger dann
aber zu stark ein guter vierter Platz
zum auftagt für ritzek den ersten
Saisonsieg sichert sich Jens oftepr vor
seinem Teamkollegen Rieber und groback
Manuel Feist wird
sie morgen mehr Wintersport mehr Fußball
mehr mehr alles mE alles danke Katja ja
einmalige Wetten große Musik Acts und
viele viele das auf der berühmten Couch
morgen heißt es nämlich wieder wetten
das zum letzten Mal präsentiert von
Thomas Gottschalk heute wird in
Offenburg schon fleißig geprobt damit
morgen dann alles glatt über die Bühne
geht und ja die nachfolgenden Sendung
sich nicht allzu weit nach hinten
verschieben los geht's in jedem Fall
pünktlich 20:15
Uhr so und so eben wird bestätigt unter
den 13 freigelassenen israelischen
Geiseln sind insgesamt vier Deutsch
Israelis
zum Wetter es wird langsam winterlich
Details gleich von Christa Orben gegen
22:10 Uhr das heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka schönen Dank schönen Abend bis
[Musik]
morgen herzlich willkommen zum Wetter
der Winter nimmt an Fahrt auf und so
liegt morgen Abend in den Alpen
stellenweise über 30 cm Schnee auch in
den Nordstau der restlichen
Mittelgebirge sind es 5 bis 15 cm die
Schneefallgrenze liegt morgen etwa bei
300 m aber in Schauern oder auch heute
Nacht können die Flocken bis in tiefe
lagagen mal für eine weiße Überraschung
sorgen und dann wird's auch Katt stellen
weil es ist nämlich frostig heute Nacht
+ 4° gibt's an der Nordsee -4° an den
Alpen wichtiges Thema noch heute Abend
der Wind in Verbindung mit Gewittern an
der Nordsee und den Berglagen sind
schwere sturmböhen möglich das lässt
heute Nacht aber nach und die Regen und
Schneeschauer vom Tag ziehen sich so
langsam in den Süden zurück an den Alpen
Schneid es sich dann ein von Norden
wird's aber erstmal Trockner erst am
Morgen kommen im Nordwesten neue Regen
und Schneeschauer auf die ziehen dann
morgen über Tag weiter in die Mitte und
den Süden verstärken sich nachmittags im
Süden noch mal und das ist dann meist
Schneefall im Norden lockert es schnell
auf nur noch vereinzelte Schnee und
Regenschauer und einige Stunden Sonnen
an der Nordsee deswegen ist es hier am
mildesten morgen mit 9° in den Alpen
bleibt es bei -1° und die Aussichten
zeigen der Winter ist ist gekommen um zu
bleiben es wird noch mal kälter am
Dienstag nur noch -3 bis + 3° und eine
neue Ladung neu Schnee tschüss